[Music]
in hard labor vacation new huh submitted
by syrup sandwiches only tour group
offered by up a chance to work in North
Korea's rice fields who the Hawks gonna
see that and see [ __ ] yeah I'm down like
who's gonna do that maybe people who are
curious about North Korea I would do it
if they didn't have a history of just
keeping tourists hostage and I have not
let them go home it's true that's true I
picture guards with aks
no no actually if this is tourism I
picture it being very luxurious I
picture it being like Oh see everybody
in North Korea has it this easy and then
you they probably give you the
state-of-the-art machines which is just
a tractor or something and they probably
make it really cool could it's for the
tours yeah they're not gonna like you're
not gonna go there and everyone's
starving and then like getting whipped
with guards they give you water with
cucumbers yeah I bet you do yeah and
there's like while people are working
there's gonna be a whole big parade with
people drumming and they're like the
village does this every day I bet you
everything is a facade you know Loki
though I really want to go but I'm
scared cuz I don't think they're like me
I think I've always wanted to go to
because uh there's a 1-point my life was
just so fascinating because it's so
weird I'd like to read up on it I would
definitely want to go you do the China
route what a China and then I would
definitely go if I meant if I was
guarantee that I would not get arrested
like Kim Jong Un's gonna come out I'm
not gonna keep you I promise
yes this Chinese based tour company
called young pioneered tours notice a
shady which is the same torquas like a
rat named young pioneer why ung yeah
it's the same tour company that otto
warmbier went to North Korea with is
that the guy that passed away he pulled
the propaganda and got work to them they
said that he did
video you can't even tell who it is
though yeah that guy he got like a
bacterial ray or something sepsis yeah
that group is now off is that they have
a new deal now yeah it's another
offering a six-day voluntourism program
that costs botulism we got isn't the
black plate you get it from canned foods
if it's like because I'm really bad or
something like that I forgot oh yeah
they're not to achieve that we did oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it costs about
one thousand four hundred and
twenty-eight dollars to be a rice farmer
yeah and so it requires the participants
to assist farmers to transplant rice by
hand I don't know and then among other
odd jobs and then they're saying quotes
on the website we've created this
program specifically to give you an
exclusive insight and experience as we
not only work hard but also play hard
eating and drinking with the local
farmers and their families and friends
after the day is done I bet you this is
a fake like Disneyland type of thing you
go there and you're like welcome to
North Korea
imagine what what if you were having
dinner like with the in the program you
having dinner and then the farmer just
slips of paper to assist me yes like
yeah let's like get out you can see it
under eyes yeah aren't you having a
great time yeah that'll be crazy you
wake up in the morning it's like they're
good I don't know I feel a little
terrible but I'm pretty sure somebody
slipped me a note I would take that note
I'd write them out it is you would cuz I
try to die as I hate this guy right here
what's on it's a game yeah yeah he ain't
faithful instead of just pretending to
so never does whole family's death will
be on your hands
he's not gonna die what what I did like
they're not people think oh yeah cuz I
gotta live
you know that's absolutely not we're all
100% pure self can't agree [ __ ] you
know what's sad though a lot of
defectors they go back to North Korea
because they're so lonely and the
culture is so different think about it
like what they're used to
yeah you spend 20 to 30 years of your
life in that environment I said everyone
that you love all your friends
everything that you know yeah that's
like in prison when you're
institutionalized so yeah and you leave
and you're just all by yourself it you
might not know how to like socialize in
this new world and all that stuff like
once you get a taste of real good Korean
barbecue or make them they say that like
the food is crazy cuz they didn't know
there were there was this much like
flavor but a lot of people just miss
their family miss their friends miss all
that stuff but you're allowed to go back
don't they just get killed a lot of
people just go back what if their
families have been killed off and they
go back like oh [ __ ] I should've never
came back oh no I have no idea yeah
anyway so this tour company they're also
claiming that the proceeds from the
not-for-profit trip will be used to
purchase goods and gasoline tickets for
the farmers helping them run tractors
and generators where you know in their
country the fuel is very scarred scarce
what if I'm assuming or I'm imagining
they're paying the guards to pretend to
be farmers so if you even was like the
Secret Service North Korea so if you
whisper anything - have you seen the
videos of Kim Jong Il's private guards
and security
yeah the old-school one right where
they're doing somersaults down a hill
and then she's shooting targets like
right in this they they're like skiing
and in breath yeah like they'll have
like a [ __ ] cinder block on their
face and somebody'll smash it and
they're like okay yeah yeah it's like
it's rigorous like they have to be able
to shoot a target dead center while in
motion at all times it's in [ __ ] same
Wow
I mean yeah it's all those little kids
playing the guitar like summer
I'm so hungry please save my family
it's pretty crazy yo this is all the
stuff that we get is our media mm-hmm
and then maybe something like the inside
look right but like if any other country
came to the US and went to the most dirt
poor impoverished part of the US and
recorded that [ __ ] and it brought it
back to their country they're gonna
think that all Americans are oppressed
hmm so I just I really want to know cuz
if Dennis Rodman Robins crazy [ __ ] ass
likes to go there and hang out all the
time
we're thinkin out with the dictator of
the country of course it's gonna have a
good time yeah what if it's like a
celebrity sanctuary well that's really
only why not eat going me yeah yeah or
like it's a it's somewhere where they
can just all go and people just like
they don't know because the one bothers
just and they don't get bothered by
paparazzi because no one can go there
you know what's a trip through all of my
studying of this stuff this is what I
think is really happening
so of course North Korea isn't gonna go
into war with anybody right like they
have a puny ass army they'll get [ __ ]
slaughtered if they go into war with
America or any like developed nation so
they just pose this threat right so they
create this like I'm gonna [ __ ] bomb
you I'm gonna do this [ __ ] and like
they're not trying to take over anybody
they just want to keep the power that
they have so the politicians know that
they know it they use that as a way to
get food so you know so just and they
purposely keep their people starving so
they could stay in power because if you
have smart and well-fed people you can't
control them that well that's right I
can't think when I'm hungry
I know this baby I know this cream guy
who is convinced that the firing of the
missiles and stuff is kind of like their
cry for help to like please invade us
and they're actually not that bad of
people does it they're like it is a
weekend like be free and how like [ __ ]
in whatever I'm like really I get all
those terrible things you hear it's not
really real but things don't happen and
I was like you're a very strange Korean
what's the easiest way to do that is to
say hey coming to my country it's the
same way without people dying right
exactly there's convinces I know it's
there they're actually not that bad they
just want help and they don't know how
to
they know how to aggravate just enough
to where they don't get anybody invading
them so like they get just enough to
where like and in our politicians use
them as fear-mongering like oh yeah so
let's keep them there so then we have
this threat in the West or whatever and
then it's like it's just a game that
they keep [ __ ] playing or he also
believe like those defectors that talk
about it now like oh they did 15 to me
you know he's like they're all actors
because they just want to be famous I
don't know about that those are some
pretty good 92 year old actors yeah the
young girl the young girl
yeah the one that does a TED Talks oh
yeah yeah he's like she's just an actor
like that's her way of getting famous
and [ __ ] yeah I don't know about that
but what I heard was her reward yeah she
millionaire just goes out on top oh yeah
I think I know what he's talking about
so they're saying like some of them fat
like exaggerated cake and
sensationalized certain things because
they were pushed to from South Korea and
it just came this like snowballing line
and they kept doing but like I don't
know you know who knows like I don't
know what they went through you know
like and then they do have actual
footage of like kids starving and all
that [ __ ] so like who knows I don't know
I heard I heard a story where there's a
mom and a daughter that tried to go to
South Korea but they had to go through
China right and so as they were
traveling to China um Chinese guards
caught them under like hey you're from
North Korea like we're gonna have to
send you back but you see did we send
you both back or we just send one of you
back and the other one can go for you
know so then like eventually the mom was
the one that went down to South Korea
and her daughter had to go back to North
Korea like so the mom sacrificed her kid
or they just chose I know I can't go to
safety and then all take the heat but
that but no no they chose for her cuz
they say that you both go back or the
mom goes to South Korea and you and the
daughter comes back to us why don't they
both go back maybe cuz the kid would
have died the kid went back there's no
one in South Korea she's not in adult
shoes and I'd do anything cuz I just
picture this lady meeting these Chinese
cards and she's like
little Cowboys America you guys like
playing Yankee and I skip ball look you
make a dollar hamburger I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]